ce qui arrive c'est que le puisard qui
est juste devant et celles qui sont sur
la rue heureusement font défaut donc il
n'ya pas de drainage adéquat et l'eau
glisse vraiment dans la sur la pente
trois inondations au cours des trois
dernières années
c'en est trop pour myriam shamsi qui
doit débourser chaque fois beaucoup
d'argent puisqu'elle n'est plus assurée
la première inondation
on a eu une perte significative
ma voiture était une perte totale
puisqu'elle était stationnée sur la
pente
mary ann shamsi possède pourtant toutes
les protections nécessaires comme la
pompe de renvoi et le clapet anti-retour
et la même érigé murets de sacs de sable
devant chez elle mais rien n'y fait
chaque fois que la fuite a annoncé dans
la météo en fait on fait un tour de rôle
donc on sort la nuit pour s'assurer que
les puisards graines comme une trentaine
de voisins elle estime que le réseau
d'égouts et son entretien sont
déficients ce que conteste la ville de
montréal qui se dégage de toute
responsabilité
c'est pas un problème d'encrassement ou
de ta structurale des égouts c'est
vraiment une question d'intensité des
pluies avec des configurations de la
topographie des pentes
selon hervé loger madame chan sied ses
voisins réside dans une cuvette
ils seraient des victimes des
changements climatiques sept ports à cas
particulier d'un puisard c'est vraiment
le phénomène d'avoir de l'eau qui
s'accumulent sur la rue qui va se
déverser dans les entrées en contrepoint
a fait la ville ne peut pas se laver les
mains et simplement drs et damages
experte en droit municipal et
environnemental christine duchesne
rappelle aux victimes de refoulement
d'égout et d'inondations que la
jurisprudence souvent joué en leur
faveur
la ville est un gardien de son réseau
elle a une responsabilité pour les
dommages causés par ce par son bien
qu'ils le réseau d'aqueduc
l'arrondissement mercier hochelaga
maisonneuve a tout de même décidé
d'installer des têtes plus performante
sur les deux pays s'apprêtent chez
madame chan s'il est d'en construire au
troisième mais rien ne change si elle
espère ne pas être et non dès cette
année ici vivent la montagne radio
canada
ja